the Joe Rogan experience yes and we're
live
hello Danica Patrick hi welcome to the
show thank you thanks for doing this I
appreciate it I'm excited to be here
you're intense lady intensity when I met
you like right away I'm like whoa yeah
take this one in well you know it's the
handshake and then it's the you know
when someone actually looks you in the
eye well you have to be intense I mean
what you do for a living is probably one
of the craziest things a human being can
do do you think so it's up there for a
job how fast you go 200 yes I mean like
you know NASCAR's top speed is probably
215 Indy cars maybe more like 240 yeah
I'm gonna do the Daytona 500 next month
and then the Indy 500 in May so those
are gonna be my last two races so the
last ones ever yeah really yeah it's uh
this is my Danica double goodbye to her
why are you doing that how come you do
in a Danica double goodbye cool is it
enough is enough I'm ready I mean I love
racing but I love other things too so
you know I'm okay with transitioning out
and there was a lot of things that were
kind of just pointing me in this
direction yeah in 2017 stuff that has
never happened to me before
- kind of yeah head towards the exit a
little bit but I'm good with it I'm a
very decisive person so this is probably
one of them that I thought about a
little bit as far as like how to be done
or or if to be done I guess but the how
was the hardest part my agent kept
calling and saying what about this and
what if you did that and I'm like no no
no you all need to get ready for me to
be done please Wow and so then he came
up with the he's like what if you finish
up at the at Daytona for the 500 and I
was like what about the Indy 500 and he
goes and I was really only referring to
the Indy 500 and he was like well I'd
I'd love you to do both I was like oh
well that's a good idea so there's this
thing in racing called the double which
is doing the Indy 500 on Memorial Day
weekend on Sunday and then flying
straight to Charlotte to do the coke 600
afterwards and that's kind of known as
the double
but this is what we're calling the
Danika double and it has to do with just
having spent you know a chunk of my
career in IndyCar and a chunk of my
career in NASCAR and it just kind of
feels like the right way to go out I
don't know it didn't it wasn't clear it
was a bit of a murky end as far as like
what's gonna happen am I gonna race next
year full-time or not and it just kind
of went suit too long for me to have
like a proper I'm done sort of moment in
my head so this was just a great way to
do it so when you say that things happen
in 2017 that didn't happen before like
what do you mean I got a sponsor leave
me my primary sponsor left at the
beginning of the year I mean I I signed
a contract it when Mercury's in
retrograde so you know I screwed myself
there but no I don't know it was true so
I guess maybe the universe is a little
bit more straightforward than we think I
think a lot of good things probably
happened during that time in 2017 or
during mercury in retrograde I think
people look for some sort of like hidden
meaning to things when it comes to like
astrology yeah yeah I do try and
understand it it's quite I'm trying to
understand how it really matters but I
don't know there's definitely some
things at least with the moon that goes
on I mean the water changes with the
moon so doesn't that mean that other
things should too whether it be
energetically or something like that I
think the water and the moon thing kind
of makes sense a little bit a little bit
mm-hmm
but I think it's probably just like
barely one way or the other maybe it's a
whisper on the wind kind of I think it's
more in your head so stop putting my
crystals outside to charge under the
full moon maybe not so important I would
say it's not that important there's
something someone sent me about the army
using crystals and I was like this has
got to be like an onion article that the
art of the army was using crystals for
like medics II think if you could see
find that way to find it wounded people
yeah look at this stupid [ __ ] I don't
know I don't know I'm sure if it's real
US Army's new holistic medics treating
gunshot wounds with crystals and
essential oils is satire thank you
essential oils don't you think there's a
plant that cures everything out there
there probably is something like that in
the Amazon that maybe not cures
everything but there's probably a lot of
stuff that we can throw essential oils
come from right yeah so pair that up
with some high vibrational stones high
vibrational stones tents so your spots
are leaving you you're like that's it
it's just a never happen to me before
I've always been someone that's been
really well funded and I always had a
sponsor always had a sponsor and never a
problem and so yeah it was just things
like that were happening I got in a few
big wrecks in a row like probably three
and six weeks that were mmm you know
like I was bawling in the medical center
after the third one going I mean I was
running like top ten and a car blew a
rotor and clipped me and put me in the
wall I was on fire another driver broke
his back I mean it was a huge accident
and I'm like what is what is the message
why does someone trying to tell me right
now and so you know after I collected my
[ __ ] and got my face looking like
halfway decent to go talk to the media
out there I finally got out but yeah I
just stuff like that was happening and I
was I was in a very go with the flow
mood in 2017 I wasn't pushing for
anything because I wasn't really sure
what I wanted so I just let the universe
take care of it you've got a very
interesting way of looking at things you
when things go wrong you're like what is
the universe trying to tell me you're
not like well I Drive really [ __ ]
fast for a living and sometimes [ __ ]
goes wrong that happens too I mean it
seems like car racing is just inherently
crazy I mean it's what I was saying what
I was saying you do one of the craziest
things you can for a living going 240
miles an hour is no joke yeah metal and
rubber and things just yeah trust in
something when you're out there because
you're doing like you said 200 plus
miles an hour with you know people that
aren't your friends around you with
walls around you as well so you know you
kind of gotta put your trust in
something else
[Applause]